[Musique]
j'avais des interviews
beau temps mauvais temps tous les lundis
le club de marche dynamique se retrouve
dans la bonne humeur à rivière des
prairies
ces visages ce sont les visages des
nouveaux recrutés comme jeanne 61 ans
ça permet de faire un peu de social moi
j'ai toujours fait d'activité physique
alors c'est une autre façon j'étais un
peu sceptique face à la marche rapide me
johanne le coeur c'est un très bon
exercice de rester en forme
selon ces spécialistes un mode de vie
actif et de bonnes habitudes
alimentaires sont à prescrire pour bien
vieillir
que ce soit au niveau cognitif physique
ou sociale en fait il faut parler des
habitudes de vie dont les habitudes
alimentaires
l'activité physique les entretenir du
point de vue cognitif la stimulation
intellectuelle et entretenir aussi ce
qu'on oblige nos qualités relationnelles
vélo marche vie sociale jacques a
toujours été actif mais plus récemment
il fait très attention à ce qu'il manque
il ya des choses qu'un je mange beaucoup
moins
legends fous ces traîtres
mon alimentation c'est beaucoup de
légumes beaucoup de fruits beaucoup de
bien
une étude révèle qu'au québec un
pourcentage élevé de personnes âgées ne
consomment pas suffisamment de protéines
soit parce qu'il est négligent ou parce
que l'organisme peine à bien les
absorber on a observé que 25 % environ
de la population âgées au québec et
consomment pas suffisamment de protéines
donc atteindre le seuil minimal de 0.8 g
par kg de poids donc la recommandation
de santé canada taxil coget de nourrice
gériatre c'est un minimum selon cette
spécialiste en nutrition
si on suit les recommandations des
experts en gériatrie les personnes âgées
devraient plutôt consommer 1,2 g de
protéines par kilo et 70% de la
population âgée n'atteint pas celle ci
on a besoin de plus de prétendants ce
qu'on est moins efficace à les utiliser
et dans essentiellement elles servent
beaucoup à l'âme amène une masse
musculaire et notre plat structure de
notre masse osseuse
[Musique]
depuis qu'elle marche trois fois par
semaine hélène sens on a noté une grande
amélioration de sa forme physique
je me déplace plus facilement mon
équilibre s'est vraiment améliorée j'ai
plus de force
jeune retraitée elle aussi elle se
demande si elle mange à 7
je mange un peu moins de protéines
qu'avant que lorsque je vivais soit avec
ma fille ou avec un conjoint jeu des
protéines animales je dis donc c'est sûr
que dans les calculs bon est ce qu'on
mange souvent la bonne quantité de
protéines végétales ou animales
je trouve que dès qu'on se perd pas
toujours facile de savoir si on mange
qu'ils amassent retire il faut
surveiller trois choses pour les sources
de protéines la qualité de la protéine 2
la qualité de l'aliment dans laquelle la
protéine se trouve et 3sat densité
protéique par exemple la viande rouge
est très riche en protéines de qualité
mais comme aliment elle renferme aussi
beaucoup de gras saturés
en revanche elle a une forte densité
pratiques au niveau de la densité
protéique c'est vraiment la quantité de
protéines dans un volume donné donc s'en
prend par exemple 100 g de boeuf cuit on
ne retranche g de protéines donc 100 g
de peuvent crise et appelle la taille de
la paume de ma main
par contre on va avoir le 30 g de
protéines sous forme de légumineuses
faudra manger de temps
les protéines sont donc essentiels mais
il ya aussi le calcium pour maintenir la
structure osseuse et la force musculaire
surtout chez les femmes de 50 ans et
plus hélène en consomment le plus
possible sous forme de légumes d'oeil au
gourou de fromage
je suis dit que je fasse tout ce que je
peux pour maintenir ma forme physique
mon équilibre la force musculaire pour
être capable de faire mon ski a le fait
pour que un host un tissu vivant pour
qu'il soit stimulée
il faut qu'un stress constant déçu que
ce soit au niveau des dents que ce soit
au niveau des genoux des hanches
alors c'est pour ça que la marge
favorise le mouvement le stress sur l'os
va favoriser parce que lost issue qui
est l'homme et qui se renouvelle
constamment
autre carence la vitamine d
surtout pour nous habitants du nord
cette vitamine fournies par le soleil et
facilement comblé par des aliments
riches en vitamine d comme les sardines
gldtons les boissons fortifiée ou encore
avec un supplément partie qu'on leur
reconnaît toutes les personnes âgées de
51 ans et plus au canada prenne un
supplément de vitamine d de 400 unités
est en national par chose
enfin il faut ajouter et insisté sur la
vitamine b12 surtout pour les personnes
qui ont réduit leur consommation de
viande qu'on retrouve essentiellement
dans les aliments d'origine animale
c'est une vitamine en fait qui a pour
rôle de favoriser la production de
cellules sanguines notamment les
globules rouges mais aussi un rôle dans
la fonction des rôles logique et
incluant le cerveau donc c'est une
vitamine qui est particulièrement
importante chez les personnes âgées ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que plus notre
corps vieillit plus il faut maintenir
une alimentation adéquate et diversifier
les bases essentiellement les masses à
dire avoir une alimentation variée qui
comprend beaucoup de fruits beaucoup de
légumes une alimentation équilibrée avec
des portions raisonnable tout est dans
l' équilibre si on veut finalement
travailler à modifier notre trajectoire
du vieillissement l'alimentation et
l'alimentation et de l'activité physique
sont des éléments de prévention sur
lequel on peut intervenir n'y est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
ayez jamais trop tard pour adopter de
meilleures habitudes alimentaires
saucier définitif c'est sûr que plus on
adoptera des habitudes alimentaires tôt
dans la vie plus grands seront les
bénéfices plus tard
[Musique]